good afternoon to you all
i'm so pleased to kick off this new
european union green week
it is wonderful to know that there are
hundreds of partner events taking place
across europe big and small north and
south and east and west
from twinned upcycling workshops in
france and germany
to online eco-quiz for high school
students in slovakia
or citizens can go to the municipal
gardens
in logrono in spain to learn about
composting
or they can find out how to reduce
plastic waste
on the shores of the black sea in
constanza in romania
if we are to save our planet
we need these kind of small individual
actions
we need them alongside the structural
changes
that we are making through the european
green deal
in the past year we have all been
confined by a pandemic
we have spent more time inside than we
wished
and as a result we have discovered
a new found appreciation of being
outside
in nature in the fields farms and
forests
that cover our countryside or the parks
the playgrounds and plazas that are
spread across our towns and cities
i believe that this appreciation for
nature
also comes with a greater awareness of
its vulnerability
it is painfully clear that human
activity has
negative impacts on other forms of life
pollution is threatening the survival
of more than one million plant and
animal species
on land and at sea it is one of the five
leading causes for biodiversity loss we
cannot be negligent any longer
thus we are determined to tackle this
challenge through our european green
deal
another truth that we are increasingly
aware of
is that the health of the planet is
closely linked
with human health the loss of
biodiversity
and the intrusion of humans into the
habitat of wildlife
is the breeding ground for pandemics
and when we pollute the planet we
pollute our own bodies and minds
one in eight death in europe is caused
by pollution
several cancers and heart and
respiratory diseases
are linked to pollution
and on top comes another issue the most
vulnerable in society are suffering the
harshest impacts
these threats affect our children
whose fragile bodies can suffer
long-term harm
they threaten the elderly and those with
particular medical conditions
and they disproportionately impact the
most deprived members of society
those who are living in poorer
socioeconomic conditions
so the fight against pollution is also
a fight for fairness and equality
it is for all of them and for mother
earth
that i presented my zero pollution
ambition for europe
i did this right after being nominated
as commission president in 2019
and i'm proud of all the work we did
last month the commission adopted our
zero pollution action plan
we're setting new 2030 targets to tackle
pollution
in all its forms to reduce it to a level
where it no longer harms human health or
the environment
and let me give you some examples
we will tackle air pollution we will
more closely align our air quality
standards
with the latest who recommendations
we will tackle water pollution by
reviewing our water quality standards
by 2030 we expect to reduce the plastic
waste in our oceans
by half and microplastics by 30
we will tackle soil pollution protecting
and restoring the life-giving ground
beneath our feet with our european green
deal
the european union walks its talk
and it takes the lead on the global
stage
yes it's a long way ahead of us
in the european union we already have
strong laws in place to reduce pollution
and we will closely monitor the
implementation by member states
and we will enforce our legislation more
strictly when needed
but most importantly our european union
is showing
that it means business we are tackling
pollution from a to z
in europe from production to waste
our aim is to lead by example pollution
and climate change
know no borders we will not protect
europeans through action in europe alone
we must also work with and inspire our
international partners
european standards have to become global
standards
we have already committed to give
protected status
to at least 30 of land
and sea here in europe
we now want to broker the same ambition
at global level i am looking forward to
the next u.n biodiversity summit in
kunming china in october
i want this global gathering to bring us
a paris-style agreement for biodiversity
i want the world to say in kunming we
have one planet
we all share it and we will all
care for it together we will reduce air
water and soil pollution everywhere
we need a race to zero in greenhouse gas
emissions
and a race to zero in pollution at well
to all of you watching listening and
taking part
in the european union's green week
events
you have a crucial role to play
let's deliver on europe's zero pollution
ambition
as you organize your events as you have
conversations with friends family and
colleagues
keep in mind this quote by margaret mead
never doubt that a small group of
thoughtful committed citizens can change
the world
indeed it's the only thing
that ever has end of quote
let's change the world together and make
it a world of
zero pollution i thank you for your
attention